أستراليا والولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة حليفان مقربان منذ فترة طويلة ،
ما ستفعله هذه الشراكة الثلاثية الجديدة
المعروفة باسم Orcis هو
رفع مستوى جيش أستراليا ليكون
أقرب بكثير إلى القدرات التي تمتلكها الولايات المتحدة
والمملكة المتحدة بطريقة مهمة جدًا لتحقيق
ذلك.  هو أن الولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة ستزود أستراليا
بمعرفة معلومات حساسة للغاية وخاضعة لحراسة مشددة حول كيفية بناء
غواصات نووية ، ومن المتوقع
أن تبني أستراليا ما يصل إلى ثماني
غواصات نووية الآن بمساعدة الولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة لتصبح الدولة السابعة فقط
في العالم لامتلاك هذه
القوة الآن تمتلك أسلحة الحرب هذه
القدرة على تغيير جوار
منطقة المحيطين الهندي والهادئ لتغيير
المسألة الأمنية هناك لأن هذه
الغواصات قادرة على البقاء في البحر لفترة
أطول للغوص بشكل أعمق لتحريك
القوى المتزايدة بشكل أسرع  لتجنب
الاكتشاف وبالطبع يمكنهم حمل حمولات أسلحة أكبر
مهما كان الرئيس بايدن
ورؤساء الوزراء جو  كان هنسون
وموريسون يجاهدون للقول إن
حمولة الأسلحة لن تشمل الأسلحة النووية ،
وهنا ما قاله سكوت موريسون
عن ذلك يوم الخميس ، أكد مرة أخرى أن
هذا يتعلق بالدفع ،
ولا يتعلق الأمر بالحصول على أسلحة نووية.
لا توجد سياسة لذلك ، لا يوجد
تفكير في ذلك ، ليس على جدول أعمالنا
الآن ، هذا ليس ترتيبًا قصير الأجل
دخلت فيه أستراليا
معنا والولايات المتحدة ، وسوف يستغرق الأمر 18
شهرًا على الأقل للفنيين من الولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة لمناقشة  مع أستراليا ، كيفية المضي
قدمًا في
خطة الغواصات التي تعمل
بالطاقة النووية ، ويمكن أن تنضم هذه الغواصات النووية إلى
البحرية الأسترالية في الخدمة في
منطقة المحيطين الهندي والهادئ ، والتي
تقول الولايات المتحدة وأستراليا على
وجه الخصوص إنها تنمو أكثر حتى عام 2040
يومًا بعد يوم ، حيث تواصل الصين
تأكيد نفسها على أنغوس واتسون سي إن إن سيدني